[Applause]
this is my office
right and this is where I keep all my
collectible
football sign football signed helmets
this sort of thing I always wanted a man
cave but there's upstairs in this helmet
right here came to Burt our first Super
Bowl sign behold impairs my collection
of all my Panther watches it makes a big
part of the team you know it feels like
family you know and the team is like my
team next thing you know we're starting
to get out of hand from one room that I
needed another one then I needed another
room and now I have a whole upstairs
2,000 square feet nothing but Panther
stuff back then everybody here had a
team from somewhere else you know
Cowboys Redskins but when the
opportunity came in 93 was to be a part
of the team but you know buying
permanency licenses we all jumped on
board 20-some years later
try to go to every game tailgate you can
tell they're real close to the stadium
with the help that they building condos
and townhomes and luxury you know
apartments all around the state and with
pushing us further and further back from
the stadium to tailgate you know is it
just as the city is growing you know
more people are coming in you know and I
know this because a lot of my clients
are in you know construction you know
contractors this sort of thing and
they're staying busy and it's just
building all around the city so
Charlotte's growing so the team is
really really brought you know downtown
back to life
[Music]
and you Jersey we've been out here since
7 o'clock this morning yeah it's gonna
be a long day but we're ready to get it
on I went into the vet office one day to
get my dog looked at and we both had
pants and stuff on and it was an
immediate bromance like we just clicked
and spent more time talking about the
Panthers than we did about the dog keep
pounding baby keep pounding
I've always been tailgating it was just
a matter of convincing dr. Mac to come
join ours so he finally came and then I
could look like 10 12 years ago and it's
been history ever since so like we
finally joined forces and it's been an
amazing little community of tailgate I
bring the music Mac brings a personality
it's all good next generation Panther
right there we always say we can't
control the football game we can control
the tailgate party and we've been
undefeated for 27 years
[Music]